our first year of being global thought
we would actually go on a little tour
and just meet directly with these three
designers so let's hear it for the class
of 2017 that's what they do for the gap
will be really really fun they are who
do I have heard yeah we're take you gap
today student gasps GQ being route
studio in Brooklyn and we're shooting
for Gigi gap trifecta with a friend from
united arrow and a me I'm wearing a meet
right now it's very me
can you put your hand in the pocket I'm
fully for say hey we're learning a new
styling trick here just collapse between
kinfolk oh yeah that's good should I get
a tattoo of this slip off on my arms wow
[Music]
there's gonna be a picture of
together well if the person's being done
I'm sad I'm gonna miss all of you guys
everything has been been perfectly this
is very exciting at this one I love it
I think it's amazing you got all the
awesome designers coming in together and
shooting like this amazing collections I
think everyone's gonna love it you guys
are gonna love it
[Music]